it was a day of solemn remembrance
at berlin's striking soviet war memorial
the public paid their respects to the
six million
red army soldiers slaughtered in the war
a ukrainian delegation visited the cold
war landmark to commemorate the 70 years
since nazi germany's surrender for
uncommon
it's not something to be celebrated you
can reflect on it through prayer or in
silence
or through quiet discussions
it's a monumental place where people are
commemorating the 70th anniversary
of the end of world war ii germans and
citizens of former soviet countries want
to set an example here together
to make sure that lessons of the past
will not be forgotten
a reminder of the past two at the
brandenburg gate
images of ruined berlin might appear
strange to young germans
but others still remember that somber
sight
barbara steiger was six years old when
the nazi capital fell
she will never forget the momentous day
all you can do is keep commemorating
these important dates
we need to state this is what it was
like and it must never happen again
millions of people died because of power
madness
if we are to remember today as a day of
liberation
we must recognize the soldiers who
enabled it to happen
and paid a heavy toll in the process
their sacrifices chiseled into the stone
at the soviet memorial
an internal reminder of the cost of
peace
you